hi there Steve coffin here today is
Boxing Day in Canada day after Christmas
there are sales in the stores but I'm
not going there because I don't need
anything by the time you reach my age
you have everything you've ever wanted
they're needed in spades
too many shirts too many socks too many
pants too many everything anyway so I
decided to do a video instead and I want
to talk about you know speaking how do
we how do we get to speaking well in the
language I always talk about input but
today I want to talk a bit about output
and I want to talk about three secrets
to perhaps hopefully becoming better at
speaking in a language first thing is
you know just do it and do it with
humility okay
allow people to criticize you accept
rejection don't worry about it you know
sometimes I hear people say well you
know I learned German and I went to
Germany and I spoke to whoever in German
and they answered in English crestfallen
well you have no right to expect that
people will humor you in German or
whatever language you're learning just
because you're learning that language
these people just want to communicate
typically I have found that even
languages that I don't speak very well
if I go to the country some people will
speak to me in the language that I'm
learning and some people will revert to
English it's just that way accepted with
humility it in a way is a form of
rejection of your effort to learn the
language but accept it yeah you know
it's a bit like me doing these videos
I get all cut I wouldn't say like I'm I
get a small amount of criticism and any
amount of criticism we will get about
our ability in another language it's
gonna be a very minor group of people
who react that way most people just want
to communicate so if I look at some of
the comments that I receive here you
know your Japanese is no good your
French is not very good one of my
favorites is they say well Steve thinks
that a linguist is someone who speaks
many languages that
that he doesn't speak languages or some
comment to that effect I mean that's
just silly in fact the word linguist as
I've said many times has for most of the
last three four hundred years meant
someone who's good at speaking languages
recently the word polyglot has started
to be used by some people some people
use it some people don't
that has nothing to do with anyone's
ability to speak languages some people
will say to you Steve you're boring so I
say well okay fine I'm boring why do you
bother you don't have to listen to my
videos so there are a small number of
these critical comments it doesn't
bother me
it's not gonna prevent me from doing my
videos I think we have to be willing to
be humiliated even humbled by a small
number of these critical comments and
just not let it bother us just do it so
to speak you have to be willing to just
do it
some people say huh I didn't understand
other people are very helpful and
encouraging you're gonna get a variety
of different reactions but the more you
speak the better you'll get you and I'll
give you some additional bits of advice
in that regard but you just have to keep
doing it you can't be so fragile that
you're worried about what impression
you'll create or whatever you just have
to do it and while I'm a great proponent
of you know input based learning at some
point we have to start speaking I've
always said the more vocabulary you have
the better you understand the better you
will do you'll understand what the other
person is saying you'll have some words
that you may or may not remember but
potentially you have these words you can
use so the more you work on your input
the better you're gonna be able to speak
but whenever you do start speaking
you're gonna stumble and whatever stage
you are at in your speaking you can
always improve so just keep speaking so
that's my first be humble accept the
fact that you're not perfect and just
keep speaking you will only improve you
won't get worse although it might seem
that you're better at sometimes than
others and it'll depend on how well you
connect with the people you're talking
to and a bunch of other factors how
comfortable you are in the environment
these or the
subject matter this will affect your you
know how comfortable how well you speak
but just keep doing it that's the first
thing the second thing is don't compare
don't compare yourself to others and I'm
gonna leave in the description box a
link to a video by a person whom I know
Christine she's French and she does
she's not a video in twelve languages
and she is spectacular
she is spectacular in languages as
different as Tamil and French and Korean
and Japanese and Russian Spanish and
Portuguese listen to this video and she
does it with humor and she it's a
phenomenal video and I can't compare
myself to Christine she's much better
than I am
that doesn't discourage me from learning
languages you know sometimes I did a
video with Luca Lumpur yalla and we
spoke can't remember which languages and
people say well look was much better
than Steve sure doesn't bother me the
fact that someone else is better than me
better pronunciation better use of words
for any number of reasons it could be
that they're simply more talented or
they have more opportunity or they went
to the country where the language is
spoken or for whatever reason it doesn't
matter people are not all going to
produce the language equally smoothly
well with equally native like
pronunciation you know close to the
native it doesn't matter don't compare
yourself also on the subject of of
humility if you look at christine's
video you'll see that she has like two
and a half million views which is
phenomenal
and she's got like 137 thousand likes
but she still got one point nine
thousand thumbs down I mean you watch
that video it's clever its witty she's
phenomenal in all these languages and
still one point nine thousand people
manage to give her a thumbs down to me
that's absolutely extraordinary again
it's a small percentage of people who
are always gonna criticize and so you
have to be humble they have a right to
criticize what they didn't like they
didn't like whatever she did that I
don't know she didn't say something
quite as well in Hindi as as she should
have or she or they're jealous or
whatever it doesn't matter so don't
compare yourself so the first one is you
know just do it be humble the second one
is
I can't remember now what was this egg
yeah don't compare don't compare
yourself there will be people better
there people that you're better than
just keep doing it and the third thing
of course and I get back to a familiar
theme if you watch Christine's video
obviously she is very alert to the
sounds and structures of these languages
that she's learned yes he had the
opportunity to be in those countries in
most cases not all but she hears it she
she's alert to it she notices it she
hears it you can't produce the language
if you can't hear it if you don't notice
how people are using the language so in
your input activities be conscious of
the fact that try to hear how the
language is pronounced sometimes it's
not pronounced the way is written as is
the case with English you have to notice
that there are certain structures you
have to be alert to that the more you
listen and read the better you become at
noticing naturally but you also have to
want to notice so whenever you go and
speak and you'll discover that there are
problems gaps words you couldn't
remember that's a good opportunity good
sort of motivation to go back to your
input activities and focus in on those
areas where you had trouble and then
expose yourself to more and more of that
because your input activities are going
to enable you to output better reading
will enable you to write better
listening is going to enable you to
speak better in particular I found are
many stories with a lot of repetition of
high-frequency verbs gave me momentum
for speaking so all of this stuff can
prepare you but when you do go to speak
just do it don't worry about it now
easier said than done for some people
who are uptight but remember you need to
be humbled you're not so precious that
you can't you know make mistakes in
front of people make mistakes in front
of people and some people may even
criticize you and it doesn't matter and
don't compare yourself to others who
speak say in your opinion better than
you don't worry about comparing and just
do it but keep working on your input
activities at the same time and that way
you
we'll and you know that applies to so
many things in life just go for it
be humble give yourself credit for what
you're able to do and go for it all
right and yeah we'll probably talk again
before through here bye for now